so I'd like to start with a story
actually so at the beating of my PhD I
was interested in how robots could learn
manipulation skills skills like what's
shown here where the goal in this case
was the robot there what wanted to
figure out how to insert that red block
into the shape sorting cube and what is
trying to learn here is a neural network
that maps from images from pixels and
taken from the robots camera to joints
are torques applied at the robots joints
and as you can see here what the robot
is able to do is through trial and error
is able to start from scratch without
having any knowledge about how to do the
task to figure out a policy that can
acquire the skill of putting the red
block into the shape sorting cube
and here's an example of the final
policy that it learned so the bottom
braid is showing the images from the
robots camera and the video of course is
showing that the skills that they're
robots learned and we were really
excited about this result so this was
back in like early 2015 and the reason
why we were really excited about this is
that we had a general-purpose
reinforcement learning algorithm that
could learn not just how to put this red
block into the shape sorting cube but
could learn other skills as well I could
learn skills like placing the claw of a
toy hammer underneath a nail for
different angles of the hammer inside
the robots gripper and the robot could
use the same algorithm for learning
whoops
for learning how to screw the cap of the
bottle successfully this is pretty cool
and and in follow-up work we also found
that the robot could use this variant of
the algorithm to also use a spatula to
lift up an object into a bowl so we were
pretty impressed with this and we were
pretty excited about this result we had
a general-purpose reinforcement learning
algorithm that could acquire a wide
range of skills and a wide range of
other labs built upon this work to do to
learn other skills like hitting a puck
into a goal such as opening a door such
as throwing an object to hit a
particular target and at the same time a
number of labs were looking at these
same sorts of algorithms for things like
playing Atari games like playing go and
learning locomotion and simulation this
is all really nice it seems like we have
algorithms that can
acquire skills automatically for robots
but we have a problem and the problem is
that the robot didn't learn things like
using spatulas lift optics and bowls and
things like like opening a variety of
doors what the robot learned was
something very specific the robot
learned how to use that spatula to lift
that object into that bowl if you change
the spatula or you change the object or
even if you change the tablecloth that's
in front of the robot the robot wouldn't
be able to solve the task and the same
is true for all the other things if you
change some small things about the
environment the policy that it learned
would fail because it was trained in
this one very narrow environment and so
in particular what all these things are
doing is learning one specific task in
one specific environment starting from
scratch now UK maybe maybe you'll say
okay this isn't a problem we can solve
this problem we can just give the robot
more spatulas right and then the robot
will be able to generalize much more
broadly I'd be able to generalize
potentially even to a new spatula but
the challenge is if you look at kind of
the learning process behind the scenes
for many of these kinds of skills you
get something that looks like this so
the robot will won't be attempting the
task through trial and error and then a
human comes in and needs to kind of put
everything back for the robot so they
can try it again in that very specific
scenario and this is my friend yet again
here and one of the things you will
probably notice here is that you have
again is doing more work than the robot
is doing this is reinforcement learning
process it's supposed to be very
automatic but in practice it's a very
manual process and it isn't practical to
collect a lot of data this way and as a
result it isn't practical to build
robots that generalize in this way with
more data and with more diversity and
the kinds of things that robot will see
there what will generalize better and so
this is a problem because we're relying
on detailed supervision and guidance and
this isn't just a problem actually with
reinforcement learning in robotics
if you look at a lot of the machine
learning systems that we have today they
can they have been able to generalize
more broadly to different situations but
they're still learning one narrow task
starting from scratch and if you want
them to do something different you have
to train them again and
the large amount of data for that new
setting and this is a problem if we care
about robots that can operate in a wide
variety of environments and can perform
a wide variety of skills for us these
are kind of all kind of very specialized
systems that are acquired through
machine learning okay and I think that
if we hope to build machines and robots
that can more generally understand and
interact with the world and so that we
can put them in any environment and have
them do useful things then we may need
to fundamentally rethink the way that we
use machine learning in the context of
robotics ok so that's what I'd like to
talk about in my talk today so I would
like to talk about how we might think
about rethinking the algorithms that
we're using when we're applying machine
learning to robotics and the data that
we're providing with our algorithms and
more specifically it seems like the
algorithms that were using can't rely as
heavily on the detailed supervision and
guidance and have to learn something
that's more general than a policy that's
tailored for a particular task in a
particular environment and we need to be
thinking about giving data to our robots
to our machine learning systems that
isn't from just one environment that
maybe is inspired by some of the
successes of things like imagenet that
can generalize much more broadly than
the robot learning systems we have today
ok
so first let's talk about rethinking the
kinds of algorithms that we're using it
seems like we need something more
general than a policy because a policy
doesn't allow us to perform a wide
variety of things in a wide variety of
situations and in particular if you
think about the the policy that was
learned for the special task what was
learned here can't be used for anything
else so clearly it seems like our robots
aren't very intelligent so what do we
want instead I think this is actually
quite a challenging problem to think
about one thing you might think about
how could we just learn a task condition
policy that's conditioned somehow on the
task and in the environment that is in
training across a wide range of tasks
and a wide range of environments I think
this will be a lot better than the
single task policies that we learned
before but it can't it can only solve
the tasks that we're seeing during
training it can't solve other tasks that
weren't seen during training so it seems
like this is still missing something in
terms of actually preparing robots for
the
a wide breadth of skills that you might
want it to perform in the future so it
seems like maybe something what we want
instead is something that is that we can
use to perform lots of tasks I
regardless of without having to know
exactly what those tasks are a priority
and in particular I think this is
basically the ability to quickly adapt
to new concepts and new tasks to new
environments such that when we see
something that we're not prepared to see
our training wasn't specifically
training us to do we can adapt to that
new situation and this is where I think
things like meta learning come in so we
want to be able to acquire a prior over
the kinds of policies and the kinds of
environments that we might see such that
that capture is essentially the
functional aspects of everything that
we've seen before such that we can
quickly perform a new task or a new
environment by generalizing or adapting
from our previous experience and so this
is kind of what what really the essence
of medal earning is it allows us to
learn the structure across multiple
tasks or multiple environments such that
learning a new task or adapting to a new
environment is very fast ok so as many
of you may not be familiar with meta
learning I I'll try to give a very brief
overview of kind of what encapsulate
SMED learning although I actually teach
an entire course on this topic and in
the fall quarters so if you want to
learn more only a few minutes won't
really do the topic justice but
essentially what meta learning is trying
to do is being able to try to adapt to a
new task and it's just specifically
trying to train for the ability to
quickly adapt um and so we can see an
example of this in the context of
supervised learning and say that we want
to be able to learn a new supervised
learning task with a very small amount
of data so as an example say we want to
learn an image classifier and in
particular we want to learn an image
classifier from five data points so you
might want to here we're given five data
points where each data point corresponds
to a different class and we want to
learn a classifier that can distinguish
between each of these five classes such
that when it's given new images new
examples it can classify those examples
as being among one of the five classes
on the left now how might we go about
trying to
of this this you shot learning problem
where you're only given five examples to
learn from well if you have data from
other image classes then you should be
able to use that data in a way that it
can prepare you for this few shot
learning tasks and in particular what
you can do is you can structure data
from other images from other image
classes such that training and testing
match you can essentially structure data
from other classes into these few shot
learning tasks such that you train it
train the model that you're learning
such that after it sees five images from
one class from one set of classes it can
generalize to new examples and you can
do this for a wide you can construct a
wide range of tasks a wide range of few
shot learning tasks such that when the
robot are or when the the system sees a
new task as shown on the top at test
time it can generalize and be able to
classify new examples from just a very
small amount of data just five examples
so this is what how many learning works
in the context of supervised learning
where we have a set of supervised
learning tasks from very very small
amount of data and we train our system
to be able to generalize from a small
amount of data but you could also
replace each of these supervised
learning tasks with say reinforcement
learning tasks or imitation learning
tasks where the goal is given one
demonstration be able to perform that
situation that that task in a new
situation or given a small amount of
experience in a new environment labeled
by a reward function you can learn a
policy from that experience okay so for
example if you want to look at any
contexts of these sorts of problems in
the context of reinforcement learning
say you want some simulated agent to be
able to quickly adapt to new reward
functions you can train an algorithm
such that after the meta learning
process you get something like this such
that it's really ready to adapt ready to
run in any particular direction and then
you take a single gradient step with
respect to the task of running forward
and you can get a policy like this and
likewise you can take this policy and
run a single gradient step with respect
to the task of running backward and you
can get a policy that looks like this so
you can essentially very quickly adapt
your hey
you're to different reward functions or
different tasks okay and you can also
look at this in the context of imitation
learning so and some of our previous
work as well we've shown that given a
demonstration for objects that the robot
has never seen before so this is a Tele
operated demonstration through a bot is
given this new demonstration with new
objects and it can learn a policy that
can adapt to the objects in that scene
such they can figure out how to place
the Apple into the bowl okay and you can
also take this I guess
one step further and try to also medal
learn in a such a way that you can learn
very quickly from other sources of data
such as videos of humans so you can for
example take a video of a human placing
the peach into the red bowl and it can
figure out that it should adapt its
behavior to the red bowl okay so this is
kind of the essence of meta learning
it's the ability to to train some
trainer policy such that it can very
quickly adapt to new situations now kind
of the question is let's get back to the
setting of trying to learn something
more general than a policy has meta
learning really accomplished this this
notion of being able to adapt very
quickly or be able to acquire new skills
very quickly based on our previous
experience now
well the tone does is that I would say
that in some ways it has we've been able
to adapt very quickly to new situations
based on previous experience but we
haven't seen the ability to adapt to
entirely new tasks so in each of these
settings the Mediterranean distribution
of tasks correspond to really like one
task with different variations on that
task like different objects or different
directions and it seems like we want to
be able to instead try to actually medal
earn across a very broad distribution of
tasks such that you could adapt to an
entirely new task and that might be able
to get us closer to a robot that can
perform a wide range of tasks so can we
adapt to entirely new tasks if you wanna
do this kind of the standard machine
learning paradigm is that our training
distribution in our test distribution
must match the same exact thing holds
for medal earning but where your task
distribution that you use for meta
training has to match the task
testing and so this means that if we
want to adapt to entirely new tasks then
we need
very broad distribution of tasks for
meta training such that we can
generalize to an entirely new task so
where can we get a broad distribution of
tasks this is the kind of the first
question if you want to study these
algorithms for with very broad
distributions of tasks if you look at
some of the simulated robotics
environments that we have you could look
at things like you look at things like
opening a gym so these have lots of
different kind of Robotics tasks that
you might consider but unfortunately
there is a lot of shared structure
between these tasks and there aren't a
very large number of tasks so it may not
be possible to try to learn a prior
across all of these kinds of tasks in a
way that generalizes to new tasks
because there might not be enough
structure to latch on to in a way that
allows you to generalize in likewise you
could consider something like the Atari
Learning Suite where you want to learn a
new game but similar to gym these tasks
don't share a lot of structure that
might allow you to generalize and learn
faster for new things more recently
there was some work actually here at
Stanford that was building a suite of
tasks called the Robo sweet house or the
surreal task this real benchmark and
this is a step closer because he's there
a lot more common structure because
they're different manipulation tasks but
there's only six tasks and we can't hope
to generalize to a new task given only
six tasks so motivated by this problem
and by the kind of the challenge of
trying to generalize to an entirely new
task we wanted to build a new benchmark
that allowed us to study that and in
particular the things that we want from
this benchmark is that we want it to
have a large number of skills so we
wanted to have at least 50 distinct
tasks we want to have award functions
and success metrics for all of those
tasks that we can actually run
reinforcement learning we want all the
tasks to be individually solvable such
that we can focus on the problem of
transfer and generalization rather than
focusing on the reinforcement learning
problem itself and lastly we want a
unified state space in the unified
action space such that there's some
notion of shared structure among the
tasks it's a motivated by this we built
a benchmark of 50 simulated manipulation
tasks so these are all shown
showing here and we're calling this the
the Metta world benchmark in a sense
that it's allowing us to study meddler
nning algorithms more broadly than what
we've been able to so far and in
particular one of the things that we
wanted to do with this eight days is
actually have a train set and a test set
such that you can meaningfully study
generalization to new tasks that the
robot hasn't been trained on before and
hopefully this will allow us to study
more general-purpose robots and robots
that can try to accomplish skills they
weren't specifically trained to do okay
so now we have this benchmark it means
that we could actually start to study a
generalization and so that's what we did
so we run we ran meta learning
algorithms on this benchmark and what we
found is that a lot of meddling
algorithms actually seem to struggle
when trying to generalize across this
benchmark and in particular if we look
at a number of state-of-the-art metal
earning algorithms like mammal our l
squared and pearl if you look at the
success rate on the meta test tasks you
get a success rate around the 20s and
low 30s so this is perhaps a bit
disappointing now one question is well
okay Why Why are they generalizing
poorly why why are they performing
poorly on the meta test set and it turns
out that they're actually doing very
poorly on the Mediterranean as well and
so this suggests that generalization
actually isn't the challenge the
challenge is actually just fitting a
very broad range of tasks with our
function approximated with with our
neural networks and so then okay the
natural thing to do is well what about
just multitask learning algorithms
algorithms that try to learn multiple
tasks this is kind of like a
prerequisite to metal learning so we ran
out a wide range of multi task
reinforcement learning algorithms and
these methods also seem to struggle when
we try to train them across all the 50
tasks in the benchmark okay so why the
poor results
what are these algorithms struggling
with so we had a range of hypotheses one
is that maybe it's an exploration
challenge so reinforcement learning
exploration as a challenge and
reinforcement learning and so maybe
they're just having trouble finding kind
of finding the skill and figuring out
how to get reward
all the tops are individually solvable
on their own so it means that
reinforcement items can't find the
solution to these these things when you
try to learn from scratch so that
doesn't seem to be the challenge maybe
it's a data scarcity problem but we gave
all the methods really plenty of data in
order to be able to learn from we also
gave the all the algorithms plenty of
model capacity so it seems doesn't seem
like it the problem with data scarcity
or model capacity but it turns out that
if you train policies independently on
each of the tasks that actually does
better than if you train policy is
jointly on the tasks so I'm still trying
to fit fit all the tasks in the data set
is actually harder than trying to fit
them individually and so from this
comparison our conclusion was that the
challenge is an optimization challenge
essentially it's having trouble
it has play of capacity to fit all these
tasks but it has is having trouble
optimizing for a policy that can perform
all the tasks successfully ok so to try
to look try to actually solve this
optimization problem we looked at a
number of prior literature on multi task
learning and some of the kind of the the
the wider the kind of the biggest number
of approaches that we saw were trying to
perform architectural solutions so they
would try to change the architecture of
the neural network in a way that could
facilitate transfer better and it's
possible that some of these approaches
could help the problem that we're seeing
but at least from our take on this
literature it didn't seem like there was
any really principled approach for
thinking about these architectures to
try to mitigate the particular
challenges that we were seeing and we
didn't really have a good sense for how
which of these architectures would
necessarily solve the problem that we're
seeing now a couple of other algorithms
instead of trying to change the
architecture tried to change the
optimization process and that was more
appealing to us so in particular what
these algorithms tried to do is try to
weight the tasks in different ways such
as if you have for example three
different tasks you try to learn a
weighting or kind of change the way that
these tasks are are weighted such that
the optimization problem is easier such
they can focus on the prop
the tasks that are making the most
progress or the tasks that are most the
most difficult for the current algorithm
but we ran these algorithms it turns out
these algorithms also didn't work well
for our setting so it seemed like it
wasn't just how the tasks are weighted
and in particular to try to control for
this we tried to very evenly sample all
the tasks and make sure the objectives
were all on the same scale so how do we
kind of solve this multi task
optimization problem well we had a
couple hypotheses for what might be
going on and our first hypothesis is
that the gradients from different tasks
are often conflicting with one another
and in particularly the way that we
mathematically defined that is that we
see this negative inner product between
the gradients of different tasks
essentially if the tasks if there's more
than a 90 degree angle between the two
gradients and this seemed like a
reasonable hypothesis because if they
were pointing in the same direction then
you would cease positive transfer
between the tasks but this can't be the
only problem because if this is the only
problem then it seems like you just
should just be able to average the
gradients and get the the direction that
effectively optimizes the the some of
the objectives and so the second thing
that we the second hypothesis that we
had is that when they do conflict they
cause more damage than was expected to
be caused and what I mean by that is
that you have high curvature in your
optimization landscape in particular we
can look at a very kind of toy
visualization of what I'm talking about
here so say you have some optimization
landscape your your the parameters are
trying to optimize their theta and the
loss function is L you have a landscape
that has high curvature that looks
something like this if you are at this
point in the optimization landscape and
your gradient looks like this say this
is the optimization landscape for one of
the two tasks that you might be trying
to optimize and maybe the other Taos is
trying to point is trying to push the
parameter director to the right and then
if that other Taos is trying to push the
parameter vector to the right then
according to the gradient you'll suffer
some increase in the loss function for
this task that would be reflected by
like this but in reality if you actually
take that step you end up somewhere like
this so the loss function that basically
the the error that you incur from the
conflict and the gradients because the
task from the gradient for the other
tasks was pushing you to the right
causes more damage in the loss function
than was reflected in the magnitude of
the gradient okay I'm sorry I processes
that we have this issue with it with
curvature right and the way that we
tried to address both of these
hypotheses is that when the two
gradients are conflicting it seems like
what we can do is try to not cause
damage to the gradient so essentially
try to solve a constrained optimization
such that you are minimizing the loss
functions of the task subject this is
the constraint that you're not making
any of the tasks worse and that might
address this challenge here where you
will try not to make this toss worse
because you made it might actually make
it worse than you were expecting to make
it and concretely the algorithm that we
came up with for doing this is to a very
very very simple algorithm I just take
your existing optimization if two
gradients are conflicting with one
another then project the gradient onto
the normal plane of the other gradient
such that it doesn't affect such as its
orthogonal and doesn't affect that
gradient and likewise do the same thing
for the other gradient so if you have
two gradients the red one and the green
one predict the blue went onto the
normal plane of the red one and project
the the red one onto the normal plane of
the blue one and then these gradients
seem like they won't interfere you might
make slower progress but it seems like
you'll mitigate the challenges
associated with under estimating how
much damage you might do by going in the
wrong direction and if the gradients
don't conflict then just leave them
alone this is a really really simple
change that you could implement and
really only a few lines of code and if
you run this on the we called this
predicting conflicting gradients or PC
grad a fairly intuitive name and if you
run this on the meadow world benchmark
we find that in comparison to training
independent models you're able to
significantly better optimize this these
tasks together and in comparison to try
to train them jointly it performs it is
able to learn and optimize as much
quicker and also achieve much greater
performance so it seems like from these
results that seems like an optimization
really was a big issue here and by by
projecting the gradients onto the tasks
were able to learn many many more tasks
than we were able to learn together
before so in the case when were trying
to train across all 50 tasks we can
solve around 30 to 35 of the tasks in a
single neural network policy and as a
side note it's also worth mentioning
that we we tried these at this type of
approach on supervised learning problems
as well such as a multi task C for
example as well as a computer vision
setting where you're trying to predict
segmentation depth and source surface
normals and what we found is that by
combining this approach with
architectural solutions to multitask
learning such as routing networks and
such as m10 you're able to boost the
performance of those approaches by a
significant margin and and really across
the board in all of the settings ok so
now you might ask ok why does this
multitask optimization work and we
wanted to kind of test if our hypothesis
about the conflicting gradients and and
changing the direction of the gradient
was what was solving the problem and one
of the things that's worth noting is
that when you project the gradient onto
the normal plane you're actually
changing both the magnitude of that
gradient as well as the direction of
that gradient and so we ran an ablation
where we compared to compared this
approach with only changing the
magnitude or only changing the direction
of the gradient and keeping the original
magnitude or direction the same and we
found first that both so so those two
ablations are shown in blue and red we
find that both changing the magnitude
and the direction is important but
changing the direction is really where
most of the gain and performance is
coming from so this suggests that really
kind of the this sort of suggest to us
at least some evidence that the
hypothesis about positive curvature is
actually what is going on in these
neural networks ok cool and this work
was quite recent I within actually the
the past few months and so our next step
here is to actually try to go back to
the meta learning setting
and actually study a setting not just
where we're training across a set of
tasks but also testing generalization to
entirely new tasks by learning a prior
with mental learning
okay so takeaways here first scaling to
broadcast distributions is hard harder
than you might think
but if you train across very broad to
toss distributions such as better world
and hopefully we'll see more benchmarks
come out in the future and mitigate
optimization issues then you can
actually get positive transfer from
training across multiple tasks and
actually sometimes train better than
training models independently on each of
the individual tasks okay
so now that I've talked about algorithms
let's talk about data so at the meeting
of this talk I showed some examples of
robots learning tasks such as such as
using a spatula or inserting a block
into a shape sorting cue and if you
think about the data that we're training
the data that the algorithm sees in this
case it has a single object or a couple
of objects it is in a single environment
and it's of a single task and so of
course we won't be able to generalize if
we feed if this is the data that we're
feeding to our algorithm right more
recently there's been some progress in
this direction so we've seen algorithms
such as that these different works they
can generalize to new objects this
includes some of the meta learning work
that I showed at the beginning but
they're still in a single environment
and are really inherently trying to
think about a single task or a single
task families such as placing objects
into containers or such as grasping
objects more recently I think we've seen
even more progress on this front so we
see a number of works including some
work here at Stanford as well that is
able to generalize to many objects and
is also looking at many different tasks
I would think is important for thinking
about generalization yet these works are
also still in a single environment and
so if you think about these works from
kind of the context of machine learning
where we're very static we're kind of
used to training on very large and
diverse
the data is still that we're training
our robots on doesn't compare to
anything like imagenet and we can't
expect anything like the generalization
of imagenet if we're training our
algorithms on this we still have like a
single viewpoint a single environment
it's really kind of a very narrow data
set now this is the machine learning
perspective like that we're not really
trading our robots on very large data
sets but from the robots point of view
maybe it's not practical to collect
imagenet for every experiment that who
want to do right so we don't want have
to collect all that data on our robot
and if we have this paradigm of setting
up an experiment collecting imagenet and
then running our reinforcement learning
algorithm or a robot learning algorithm
a lot data set that's not going to be
practical in the future we can't replace
this clock data set with a collect image
net step so instead I think we need to
be thinking about how we can try to
accumulate and reuse data across
environments and across institutions now
the challenge here is that every
institution has their own robot has
their own experimental setup has their
own camera and so what this means that
we need to start investigating whether
or not we can share data across robot
and across robot platforms across lab
environments across experimental setups
and if we can do that then I think we
can actually start to get to the scale
of something like imagenet ok so can we
accumulate data across labs that kind of
one of the questions that we wanted to
study and the kind of the first step to
studying this question is actually just
collecting a data set and so that's what
we did we collected a data set that is
somewhat summarized by the visual here
that has seven different robot platforms
in it including soy or franca baxter
fetch cuca widow x and a robotic google
it has a hundred and thirteen camera
viewpoints across the different
experimental setups it has 15 million
video frames so it in quantity is also
quite large and it was also collected
across four different institutions and
so and for each of these robots it isn't
just a new robot platform
but it's also at a different institution
with a different experimental setup and
also importantly is open for
contributions this I think that this is
still doesn't really compare to
something like imagenet but it's getting
closer to that setting okay so then we
need to actually test if these this data
set is useful if we could actually use
this data set in a meaningful way to aid
in generalization and this question is
non-trivial because we're very attuned
to the set up where we're learning in
one experimental setup with one robot
and so what we do is we need an
algorithm that can learn from offline
data sets and a lot of reinforcement
learning algorithms are kind of learned
instead from this online experience
that's collected from the policy
probably than an offline data set and so
we took an approach from some of our
prior work that can learn from offline
data sets that basically what it does is
Klotz data it learns a model from that
data so in this case it's learning a
model of what the next images will look
like given the current image and the
sequence of actions so you get videos
that look like this it's basically a
neural networks basically a dynamics
model but individual space and then once
you learn how to predict you can plan
using that model using your favorite
planner as long as it can scale to video
projection models okay so this is the
approach that we'll use to try to learn
from the data and to evaluate whether or
not it's useful we will we'll take the
data set that we collected which we're
calling somewhat shamelessly romanette
inspired by image net we're gonna hold
out one of the robots we want to be able
to test if this if this data is that can
be used to generalize to an entirely new
robot so we hold up one to the robots
and then we fine-tune on a new robot
platform and we're not just fine-tuning
to a new robot we're actually fighting
to a new robot a new environment and a
new set of objects a new camera view
point essentially an entirely new
experimental set up and when we
fine-tune the video picture model on
this data we then evaluate the model on
basically the planning algorithm on a
set of tasks and what we see is that if
we for example hold up
cuca fine-tuned on this set of data we
get a success rate around 40% whereas if
we trained from scratch on only 400
Shrek trees from the cuca we get a
success rate that's significantly lower
that's around 10% and even if we
actually train from scratch on the cuoco
was significantly more data with 1800
directories we still perform worse than
if we pre trained with the Robo net data
set and fine tune on the cuca now you
might say well maybe this is just a cuca
we also ran experiments on the franca
where we held out the Franken and
fine-tuned on the franca and we're in
getting seeing this performance
improvement from pre training on this
much more diverse data set of robot
interactions and we also ran experiments
on a Baxter as well and we also saw AB
gain from 50 from 33% to 58% by
pre-training on Robo nut but the last
thing that we observed in the setting is
we ran an ablation where we also pre
trained on only Swire data and then
fine-tuned on the Baxter data and this
this method actually performed the best
so this is Justin to us that there's
actually a lot of work to be done with
these very large data sets because we're
essentially seeing underfitting when we
add data on top of the Sawyer data we
are performance degrades and so that
means that we're not capturing the
diversity of the data and capturing all
of the information that's in that data
in that data because our model isn't
able to fit that data so in general we
view this hopefully as a step in
contrast to kind of the things that I
show the beginning
hopefully the step towards more
generalizable learning more
generalizable skills and more open world
environments but of course a lot of
important directions for future work to
try to mitigate some of the challenges
associated with fitting these very broad
data sets okay and then one last thing
is what about other data so we I showed
how we can use data from other robots
but there's lots of other data that's
out there lots of other video data for
example on the internet there's lots of
videos of humans doing things and it
seems like we should be able to leverage
that data in ways that also inform how
to act in the world so as an example if
you go on YouTube or on the internet you
can find videos that look like this for
simple or maybe in a more modern area
you might find more modern videos in
these videos I think are actually
provide a huge opportunity for us
because first there are a very broad
untapped source of data but I contain
many many interactions in many many
environments and second they include
more sophisticated interactions than the
kinds of interactions that we can
collect at scale with robots they
contain interactions of people using
tools and people flipping objects using
a frying pan for example so it seems
like if we can use this data then we
might be able to learn more complex
skills and also be able to generalize
more broadly but there's a number of
challenges of course so first there's a
huge domain shift between the kinds of
videos that we'll see here in the kinds
of videos that our robot is observing
and second we can't access the actions
that were taken by the human so we can't
directly figure out how the human was
doing the things that they were doing
and even if he could access the actions
the actions wouldn't correspond to the
same action space of the robot ok so
because of some of these challenges we
wanted to take a first step in this
direction and the way that we wanted to
do that is to learn from videos of
humans in the robots environment and so
in particular we wanted to see if the
robot could learn how to use a variety
of tools by simply watching humans use
tools so what we did is we took that the
some examples basically took videos of
humans using tools this data is really
easy to collect in comparison to
teleoperation data of the robot using
tools and we also use the interaction
data such as the kind of data that we
had in rub-on of robots interacting
randomly in the environment and from
this data we learned a pretty printed
model of videos and then planned using
that model to accomplish tasks now the
key challenge here is how do you learn a
predictive model with in settings where
you don't have the actions and where you
have domain shift and the way that we
approach this problem is we formulate a
graphical model underlying kind of the
data that we have and in particular we
decided to model
well first we could only observe the
and half of the time so we have this
semi observed action variable where it's
only observed in the setting where you
have interactions and not observed in
the setting where you have where you
have observations and then we have a
latent action variable Z that's modeling
essentially the intentions of the agent
whether it be a human or a robot and
lastly we have a domain variable D
that's capturing basically the
differences between the robot domain and
the human domain and this is observed
because we assume that we know whether
or not we're looking at a video of a
human or a video of the robot and then
we essentially augmented our video
prediction model with these latent
variables and then optimizing used using
variational inference by optimizing the
evidence lower bound okay
so how does this work the first question
is can we model can our model leverage
the observation data to improve and to
do this we compared first to SAV P which
is a standard video prediction model but
that doesn't have the ability to learn
from videos of humans so it's only
trained on the random robot interaction
data and we also compared to an Oracle
that was the standard model but was
trained both with random robot
interactions as well as demonstrations
kinesthetic demonstrations of robots
using tools where we can observe the
actions and what we see is these are two
standard video prediction metrics that
measure the quality of the predictive
model that was learned and we see that
we're able to outperform a model
distrained only on the random
interaction data and also start to
approach the model that is trained with
kinesthetic demonstrations we we think
this result is significant because even
trying to make use of the robot data and
trying to get anything out of the rob
sorry the human data is is I think it's
really a hard problem but of course
these metrics aren't very useful and
really the question that we actually
care about is can this observation data
improve performance can the robot
actually learn how to use tools and and
you basically perform tasks that require
tools better by leveraging the
observations of the humans and so what
we did is we evaluated the robot on a
sequence
tasks and particularly we gave it tasks
such as trying to move objects trying to
move a set of objects to the right where
it's gonna be a lot faster you use a
tool to use basically this pencil case
is a tool to push the objects over to
the right and the robot can figure out
by planning with its learned predictive
model how to grasp the object and move
and use it to push the the erasers close
to the pencil and we also give it other
tasks so in this case the goal is to
push a pair onto a plate and the robot
can figure out how to grasp a grasp
spatula and push it on to a plate and
likewise there's a task we had a task of
pushing some trash near a dustpan and
the robot can figure out how to grasp
the sweeper and use it to push things
near the dustpan and quantitatively we
want to study if the observation day is
actually improving tasks performance and
compared to just using the interaction
data and we find that we see a
significant gain and the success rate by
using the observation data so
essentially the robot was able to use
both seen and novel tools by watching
humans use tools okay so to conclude
this part of the talk I think that if we
want robots to be able to generalize we
need them to be able to we need to be
able to accumulate and use all of the
available data that we have at hand
whether it be data of robots and other
labs or data from humans and hopefully
this will be kind of a step towards
towards making machine learning methods
for robotics much more generalizable and
I guess it's also worth mentioning that
this idea really isn't new this is kind
of the approach that everyone in the
machine learning community has been
taking to build more generalizable
models of language models of images etc
and so I think that this is really
really a step towards trying to take
robotics outside of really kind of the
dark ages a machine learning where
you're only training your machine
learning models on these really tiny
data sets okay
so in summary I talked about how we can
try to rethink algorithms and rethink
our data such that we can try to scale
the very broad toss distributions by
mitigating some of the optimization
challenges
and to accumulate large and offline data
sets with off policy model-based
reinforcement learning algorithms I
think that hopefully by doing so we can
maybe kind of bring ourselves one step
closer to having robots that can more
generally perform tasks in a wide
variety of environments now what's next
I like to talk a little bit about some
open challenges and maybe where we're at
with regard to those open challenges and
to do this I'd like I really like to
think about just a very concrete example
of something that's maybe remarkably
challenging for the current things that
we have today but also remarkably easy
for humans so say for example you have
some environment maybe a kitchen
environment and you put your robot in
that environment and maybe this is a
kitchen that the robot has never seen
before
kind of the open challenge is just let's
see if the robot can make us a bowl of
cereal in that new environment this task
I mean for those of you that are
familiar with some of the challenges of
Robotics this is in many ways I think
like really a grand challenge this is
something that's remarkably challenging
but of course for humans this is really
a simple challenge and I think that if
we can think about steps that can bring
us closer to going in a new environment
and doing really a simple skill in that
environment but maybe a skill that
requires reasoning about partial
observability reasoning about long like
kind of dependencies in in the sort of
longer horizon tasks then we might be
closer to having systems that are more
intelligent and have more common sense
and to get to kind of something that a
system that can do something like this I
think that we need basically to
basically to get to intelligent behavior
and open world environments I think we
need systems that can continuously learn
and improve from data that they collect
in the real world such that they can
start with more simple skills like some
of the skills that we saw earlier but
towards more and move towards more and
more generalizable environments and more
and more complex skills and in this sort
of processing that there are a number of
challenges I think the other and I think
that we can try to address some of those
individual challenges now so things like
adapting to
new environment that you haven't seen
before and one way that I think we can
do this is actually in the context of
metal learning so we can view the online
adaptation problem as if you shut
learning problem and we have a little
bit of work and I'm trying to see how
we're all what's gonna adapt with very
small amounts of data to new
environments another challenge and
another kind of important step towards
moving towards the school I think is to
move towards longer horizon tasks so a
lot of the things I talked about today
we're relatively short horizon skills
and it seems like we need to figure out
how we can bootstrap from those short
hires and skills towards longer horizon
skills and one way that I think we can
do that is through things like
hierarchical abstractions we have some
some early work on this direction where
we try to optimize for sub goals such
that we can string together a sequence
of short skills to perform a longer task
and lastly I think one considerable risk
here is that if we want to continuously
have our agents continuously learn and
improve in to perform like more and more
difficult tasks and perform in more and
more general environments then one
challenges that might come up is what if
the improvement is too slow what if we
won't ever actually get to the kitchen
environment at the end because the
process of getting better is just simply
too slow and I think that this is where
things like meta learning can actually
come in as well I think that if we can
over the process of learning a sequence
of skills at the beginning learn very
slowly because we're learning from
scratch but over time get faster and
faster at learning based on the
experience that we've seen so far
then we might be able to accelerate this
process of improvement and hopefully get
towards the more challenging
environments more quickly okay lastly if
you're interested in learning more about
some of the algorithmic challenges and
algorithmic advances in this direction
as I mentioned earlier I'm teaching a
course on multitask learning and medal
learning in the fall quarters and
actually all of the the lectures will
also be available on YouTube your SCPD
in the future and also in the context of
reinforcement learning I start I helped
form a course at Berkeley on deep
reinforcement learning
which has been continued to taught in
all the lecture videos that there are
also available online and really these
two courses capture a lot of the kinds
of algorithms and methods that I was
talking about today and of course
there's also reinforcement learning
courses at Berkeley such as some of the
courses that have my broad skill teaches
for example okay and with that I'd like
to thank my my students and my
collaborators and I'd be happy to take a
few questions
thank you yeah yes I have two questions
but there's a thanks to the great talk
it's really nice that yes one is about
like the generalization performance how
do we really know the limit so when we
train a robot it's not going to work in
all possible environment so before
deploying the robot how can we really
know understand the limitations and the
second question is like so this has all
these tasks are very different to say
imagenet where the robot really has to
interact with the environment do you
think it's better to take very good
quality data rather than a lot of data
and is there a way to do that yeah the
first question and I think this is a
really challenging question a--basically
once you learn some behavior or some
policy or some model how do you know the
kind of the extent of the generalization
of that setting and in general I think
that in many ways sometimes like in some
ways this falls under the problem of
uncertainty quantification like given a
model and given a new data point can my
model tell me whether or not it can
generalize to the data point or not and
there's been a lot of work in that
direction and I think it's making some
progress although in the context of deep
learning and neural networks it's a very
very challenging problem the other thing
worth mentioning is that I think that if
we hope to generalize that thing then we
should just try to broaden our training
distribution such that we could hope to
cover that TAS or that setting that
you're gonna see that data point that
you're gonna see at test time and I
think that in many kind of cases when
you think about generalization you think
about okay given my dataset can I get my
robot to generalize but I think that the
better way to do is like how can I
brought in my dataset
and get my algorithm to work on that
data set so and think about how ways
that you actually go about collecting
very large data sets and that's
essentially the kind of work that I was
showing towards towards the end where we
want to generalize and use data that's
very broadly applicable and covers the
kind of situation so you might want to
see a test time regarding the second
question you're asking about the when we
collect data for robots we have we want
to collect interaction and we may want
that interaction to contain more
sophisticated interactions with the
world basically focusing on quality over
quantity and I think that this this this
question is actually is really important
and I think that we should I showed
today a set of that we're calling Robo
net of completely random interactions
with with objects and if you wanted for
example learn how to use a spatula to
lift up an object like that data isn't
going to help you very much you aren't
going to get very far to performing that
very complex task and so I think that we
need to be thinking about both both
quality and quantity when we clock these
data sets and one of the things that we
want to do next in the say is that is
start to augment it with more
sophisticated interactions so there is
some other work at Stanford called Robo
jerk for example that is looking at how
we can really scale teleoperation and
that might be one way to get more
sophisticated interactions of robots
interacting in a wide variety of
settings but you can also imagine using
reinforcement learning as well so if you
actually start learning from this data
and start learning skills and you
actually deploy policies that are
learned to collect more data in a wide
range of environments such that you can
start to get more interesting
interactions and and interactions of the
robot actually trying to do tasks in a
very goal-directed way while still
trying to maintain the quantity because
I think the quantity and really the
breadth not necess the quantity but the
breadth of the data is gonna be really
critical for generalization yeah about
the breadth of the data set just
thinking about the difference between an
image net and the tasks associated with
it which tend to be classification
segmentation you know counting instances
whatever as a high dimensional input
space perhaps in terms of the number of
pixels and their values but in the
output space is fairly small but for an
interaction task both are so much bigger
you have a whole environment you can
have
all kinds of images coming in in the
video input whatever your observations
are and your decisions are extended over
time yeah and you're having you're
choosing a whole trajectory so could we
maybe say that speaking about broad data
sets is like like intractable like you
you just can't have Brett in the sense
that image then has Brett that makes
sense both breath in in some cases
because it has so many environments and
so many objects but in other ways it
actually doesn't have that much breath
because it's only the kinds of images
that a human would take like with the
camera it doesn't contain like all of
the other kinds of observations that a
robot sees that a human sees because it
was teddy was taken from like like
Flickr or something like that they're
basically like things that humans would
take pictures of and that actually
doesn't capture a wide range of images
that robots might see in the environment
especially mobile robots and and
basically like all these sorts of
viewpoints that you might not see and so
in some ways that kind of the breadth
that we might need for robots actually
might be much broader than what we need
for something like imagenet so that's my
first thought the can collect that kind
of threat and you need like to the kids
point where you can say this is a broad
base you know because there's so much
more to collect
yeah it seems like we should have to be
better off in robotics then imagenet
because we can have robots collect the
data for us
whereas for things like imagenet and
computer vision like we're having humans
collect the data and we actually have
like if we can get enough kind of
low-cost robots for example out there
collecting data then we may actually be
able to collect data that spans a really
wide range of situations and and maybe a
much wider range of situations and the
kinds of things let me see with imagenet
so I think that there is there is some
hope there for trying to capture that
really that feeling broad distribution
but at the same time I do think that
really there's gonna be situations that
the robot sees at test time that aren't
that aren't captured in that simply
because of how huge the spaces and I you
know are situations and where humans are
in that all the time and we'd also need
algorithms that can reason about
situations that they haven't been in
before and kind of understand things
more broadly and I think that that's
really a tremendous challenge as well
beyond just capturing broader data but
just final follow-up on that you
mentioned at the end hierarchical
abstraction but I think is the key for
humans being able to deal with so many
tests even unseen as you know understand
able to plan in a very low dimensional
space in comparison to
[Music]
yeah so I think the part of the key is
so I think that collecting is brought of
day as we can is it makes a lot of sense
but part of the key also is you but you
don't want to model everything because
if you try to have your neural network
model all of that data then you like
you're just gonna hit a wall at some
point because it's because like it's not
possible to model everything in the real
world and you have to figure out what to
discard I'd agree on what to discard is
really I think also a critical challenge
and the somehow that what you discard
actually needs to also be informed by
functionality by semantics and and some
of that is gonna have to come from
humans so instead of trying to model
everything you could try to model only
the tasks that humans care about similar
to some of the meta learning things I
was talking about like only model a
prior over those tasks relevant skills
or human relevant skills but then the
challenge there comes in is like how do
you define the things that are relevant
does it is it a human is it some some
part of the algorithm that's kind of
trying to figure out what to discard and
what to keep and I think that that that
sort of kind of it sort of like a
compression view on artificial
intelligence like what do you what do
you keep and like in a lossy compression
scheme what do you keep and what do you
throw out and that that I think is a
challenge into what we do is we we for
each task in the batch we do the same
procedure because we want to be
symmetric and then we free toss and
about to be randomly sample an order of
all the other tasks and then do it
iteratively where you first look if it
conflicts with the first one if it does
you project then you take the result of
that go ahead and go down to the second
task
okay thank you
[Applause]